thank you well good evening everybody
and welcome
um to the first meeting of the latest
incarnation of the local plane cabinet
advisory group and uh
welcome back if you were part of the
previous one and welcome for the first
time if you were
if members have any technical
difficulties during the meeting please
contact the democratic services officer
on caller will attempt to
assist you today's democratic services
officer is katie brewer
and her number is 577046
it will also be at the top of the chat
thread for members if you need it
participants when you're not speaking
please mute your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side of the screen
i'll make a note and go back to you once
the person speaking has finished
with everyone please ensure their mobile
phones are turned silent and they're not
used to make or receive phone calls
while the meetings in progress
please ensure that you're in a quiet
room free from distractions for the
duration of the meeting
so can i ask the members of the group to
confirm that they're present in the
meeting when i read out your name
councillor ashby hitcher
councillor bailey here chair councillor
robert byford
president chair councillor farance
council of fellows evening chair
thank you councillor ghana i'm here
chair
castle hopkinson i'm here
yep and councillor linda piper
so it looks as if we're short of council
linda piper and councillor farence at
the moment
that's correct yeah okay
um i haven't received any requests to
speak under council procedure 20.1
um i don't think there's anyone else
present who could put themselves forward
that i can see
um we haven't received any apologies
charles have we
no we haven't okay we'll probably see
whether the other members turn up as the
meeting
uh proceeds are there any declarations
of interest anyone have any interest in
declaring the items of the business on
the agenda
today i'm not hearing any thank you
so the first item is a presentation to
introduce the local plan update process
and to highlight the key matters for
debate and that's over to mr verrell
thank you very much uh good evening
members um
i'll just check that you can
see the presentation
can you see that
thank you bob
so this evening i just want to cover a
few topics one
is just a general
coverage of the update process
a quick sort of review of the update
topics which were considered
by the review group and then i want to
cover
uh four other issues one relates to the
examination
and soundness issues
uh the role of evidence gathering uh the
importance of sustainability appraisal
and habitat regulations assessment
and duty to cooperate and obviously if
members have got any questions
i will take those at the end if that's
okay
so the local development scheme
the work program was published in
december
that is i've given you there a link and
charles is going to send round
presentation afterwards so you can see
the lds itself that extends the local
plan horizon
from 2031 to 2040
and there's a range of issues that were
identified by the review group
and obviously the role of this group is
to consider those issues in a bit more
detail
and make recommendations to cabinet
later this year
i'm not going to say very much about the
timetable except to say
that it is quite a tight time scale
and envisages adopting a plan by the end
of 2023
this is to try to fulfill
the government requirement that we have
full plans in place by the end of 2023
i've grouped the issues that were raised
during the review process under sort of
a number of headings first one is
environment
and members who part of that review
group will
remember these quite well i'm sure but
i'll quickly cover them
the implications of climate change the
link
between climate change and biodiversity
biodiversity net gain
and green infrastructure
issue about electric vehicle charging
points
and to update other policies as
necessary depending on the progress of
the environment bill as which as
members will know has been delayed until
the autumn
uh the kent environment strategies and a
number of other
pieces of policy and legislation
in relation to housing
to need to look at the local needs
housing methodology and the impact that
has on
housing requirements for the district
beyond 2031 up to 2040
and to look also at the provision of
gypsy and traveller science to meet
the requirements that were identified in
the study that was published during the
examination
so we are currently running a call for
sites
uh that's been running for about a month
and finishes on the 21st of may
and members will also remember that
um cabinet decided that we should be
looking for a directed stopping site and
that should progress through the local
plan process as well
we may also need to review a number of
some of the more tricky urban sites that
haven't come forward
to see if we still think they're capable
of delivery
on the economy one of the key things
that the inspectors raised was the need
to
update the plan in relation to the dco
as things stand we don't have a final
decision on that
but hopefully that will progress to the
point where we can address that
in the local plan process there may be a
need to
identify some additional employment land
uh we've started work on reviewing
the home working policy to see if
there's anything else that we can look
at
that can assist that
there is a report about
the future of landscape pool and harbour
which has been itself the subject of
some consultation and obviously
we'll need to understand what's coming
out of of that process
uh insofar as it affects the local plan
the members will also recall we had a
discussion about community wealth
building program
uh but as part of the review and we'll
need to look at the planning
implications arising from that as well
in relation to retail and town centres
obviously things have changed
dramatically over the last couple of
years
particularly as a result of kobe 19 and
shopping patterns have shifted
quite dramatically we had some work
carried out by
a company called litchfields who i hope
will be able to present
those findings to you directly at our
next meeting
um they looked at what retail floor
space might be needed in the future
but they also looked at shopping
patterns they did a telephone
shopping survey of tagnet residents
as part of that process
and members may also be aware of
the changes to the permitted development
rights and the use classes order
which probably needs to change the way
that we necessarily look at town centres
and their role
and obviously we have things such as the
margate town deal
which involves
quite a lot of investment in the town
centre and obviously we'll work with
those
working on town deal to see if there's
anything that the local plan can say
to support that
um and i've just gathered some other
points under what i've called other
issues
there are infrastructure policies at the
last local plan
examination we published a
infrastructure delivery plan which
looked at transport health education
utilities and various other things and
we may need to update those
we also had a discussion in the review
group regarding a potential hot food
takeaway policy
and the other matter that was raised was
can we
look at resilience measures to address
coved or any other similar threats
to the social and economic economic life
of the district
and again that's something that we're
currently looking at
i should say that the local plan has
adopted does have quite a lot of
policies in relation to these issues
but it may be that some of those need
dramatic change others need
more subtle changes but obviously the
idea will
be that we will bring those
possibilities to you for discussion as
an advisory group
i just wanted to touch on the issue of
soundness we start to
drift into a certain amount of planning
jargon here i'm afraid but
the soundness tests are what
is addressed at the examination the
examination
is carried out by independent inspectors
and the four things they look at are the
soundness tests so
i thought it'd be useful just to run
through those because
when we bring reports and
recommendations to you
in the backs of our minds all the time
are these four tests of soundness
so first one is positively prepared
providing a strategy which is a minimum
seeks to meet the area's objectively
assessed need
and also if it's possible to help
meet unmet need from other districts and
obviously
the issue of unmet need and who meets it
works in
in different directions as well
the second test is justified and this is
really about evidence
and i think i made uh
an emphasis on this when uh at the
member briefing a couple of months back
that uh it's always important to have
evidence to back up your policy position
and i won't say much about proportionate
evidence
uh i've been involved in numerous
examinations now
and uh whatever you think is
proportionate
is almost always never quite enough
um but it also says that we need to look
at reasonable alternatives and i'll come
back to that in a minute when we talk
about
sa part c
effective means we have to demonstrate
that it's deliverable over the plan
period and it's based on effective joint
working
um on cross-boundary strategic matters
so this is the duty to cooperate and
again i'll come back to that
in a minute but essentially what they're
saying is
you have to show that you've tried to
deal with those matters
rather than deferring them as it says
there
and generally also to be consistent with
national policy
so they're the four tests of soundness
evidence space i have talked about
before i've just listed some of the
things that are going on at the moment
so the strategic housing market
assessment
retail capacity study transport
modelling hasn't begun yet but it's
something that we're working with kcc
on in in the background
and the call for sites i've already
mentioned
sustainability appraisal and habitat
rigs assessment these are two
critical parts of the process they are
both statutory
so they are they're not optional they
are part of the process
the essay uh the purpose of that
primarily is to show that you've
considered
different policy options and that you've
selected an appropriate strategy
then you have to consider what called
reasonable alternatives
the habitat regulations we have certain
legal duties under the habitat
regulations
which apply to plans policies and
programs
and we have to show that we have done
that
and land use consultants are acting as
our advisors on this particular piece of
work
and largely duty to cooperate as it says
there at the third bullet point this
isn't a duty to agree
but it is a duty to address
cross-boundary
issues seriously and to seek solutions
wherever possible
i.e dealt with rather than deferred
we have we're quite fortunate we have
regular meetings with the east kent
councils to discuss matters of common
interest on local plans and
other policy issues so we meet quite
regularly with
canterbury dover ashford and foxton
highs
and we discuss a number of issues
including sort of best practice and
how we can pull together the statements
of common ground that are mentioned
there
so the issues can cover all sorts of
things
historically the issues that tend to be
raised are things around transport
the transport network across east kent
natural environment
particularly at the coast and as i said
we are required to produce statements of
common ground now
that go to the examination i have to say
this this is one of the first things
that inspectors
test if you don't meet the duty to
cooperate
in that first instance that can bring
your entire examination
process uh to a halt
so they're the four areas i wanted to
cover in a
sort of in addition to the topic areas
because i think they're quite important
they're quite
urgent in terms of starting to work on
those things early on in the process
and they are things that the inspectors
will look at examination and so
therefore are important to getting
a plan adopted
um i'll leave it there i'm happy to take
any questions that members of
of god thank you thank you adrian
um just just before i bring councillor
garnering i think it might be worth
you saying something about how this
group works because
we've got a number of new members um
and i can say as chair that it's not a
decision-making group it has no powers
under the council's constitution
so can you just explain how it how it
flows into the process of
producing the update yes i think i will
yeah um
yeah the purpose of this group is really
to have some consideration of all these
different issues we'll bring to you
evidence and reports and various other
things and
the intention would be that at the end
of this process
um a number of recommendations on those
points will go
firstly to cabinet before we go out to
consultation on the local plan
so it is an advisory group but obviously
we want to hear your views
and at the end of the process we'll pull
together a report for cabinet which
addresses all the different topics i've
raised i
hope that covers the point thank you
um councilor garana thank you
thank you very much yeah thank you
adrian um yeah it's a very um
thorough list of of um items i
i did i have previously checked against
the report from the last review group
and
does seem to cover everything um one
comment though you you mentioned the
leveling up fund
um you you call it the ramsgate living
up front i know
all the discussion around the leveling
up fund has
sort of focused on ramsgate being the
center of attention for that but it is
in fact uh
it is a planet planet living up fund
isn't it
so um there will be i know there are
conversations that are going to be
taking place
um because uh harry's like broadstairs
is gonna um have a claim for
or want to be discussing receiving some
of that for various
issues in the town um so i was just
really making that point
yeah thank you and we we can certainly
pick up points from the various towns
about
how we approach the town centres that's
for sure yeah
okay councillor bayford
yeah thank you chairman um yeah i want
to adrian just to sort of ask you
to elaborate a bit more when you you
sort of describe what what this group's
purpose is and
so it seems to be a bit of a sounding
board to get opinions and whatever
but we're a fairly diverse group and i
think it's fairly
going to be fairly obvious that some of
us have probably got things that we feel
quite strongly about and they're likely
to be opposing views within the group
how would you go about deciding what
this group is actually saying in terms
of taking it forward and putting in a
recommendation
i think when you look at the i don't
know whether it's
included in the full program but the
idea would be
at one of the final cags for us to come
to you with a set of recommendations
so obviously
from what you're saying some of those
recommendations may please some and not
others
uh but obviously we'll try to take into
account people's views there are going
to be
some difficult decisions to make uh i
appreciate that
um but we will obviously come to you
with what we believe to be
recommendations
based on the soundness points and what
we think
we can defend when we get to examination
and obviously there will be discussions
about those recommendations so i hope
that will
provide the sort of right level of
ability for people to add comments and
um
and to debate the issues
quick uh can't rashby
thank you chair um going back to um
adrian thank you for the
presentation um on the duty to cooperate
have you got any actual examples of of
where
um what areas have been covered with
that actually been covered
in the past just uh be nice to know what
what sort of things you you've actually
come across in that particular area
yeah of course um the probably the main
one from the last
local plan was issues around
impact of development on the transport
network so
uh there was a quite substantial amount
of transport modelling done
that was overseen by kcc um
and the two issues that came up were
from
highways england in relation to the
junctions
at brenner corner where obviously the
tannic way
joins m2a2 and the other a2 junction
with the a256 in dover
the other issue was raised by canterbury
uh regarding the impact on the a28
because obviously
that that is not a um it's a busy road
uh there are obviously issues around
sturry already
um so what we did was to do uh
two reports uh from the modelling one
was
about the impact on the strategic road
network so that's the a2m2
which we agreed a methodology with
highways england and then prepared a
report
uh i these are on the council website
they're on our examination pages so they
are still there
and the other one was uh what we called
an
a28 technical study so again that was
looking at
the potential impact of traffic on the
a28 resulting from development in sani
and obviously they have to do similar
things for their plans as well
and we then shared those reports with
highways england andover and canterbury
and those reports were agreed what they
essentially showed was
actually the impact was relatively minor
and so uh although potentially it could
have been quite a serious cross-boundary
issue
the work that we've done in terms of
transport modelling and reporting
uh demonstrated that it wasn't uh as
significant an issue
uh certainly as highways england thought
it might be
so that's that's that's a typical sort
of example of
the kind of things we need to do thank
you
councillor yeah thank you uh
chair thank you adrian for the
presentation um
i just wanted to ask about um
infrastructure
and health services um because
i know that in the um planning
applications they include things like
the you know cost towards um education
and cost towards
uh building an extension on a gp surgery
and things like that
um but the real concern is that it is
actual
um gps and
health workers generally and our
services at qeqm
which are being down you know which are
being diminished um
all the time so particularly for gp
services i might just hone in on that
one um
we don't have enough gps in planet as it
is it's it's we're in dire straits in
fact as admitted by the ccg
so i wondered what the um what was
actually happening
to um encourage
us what to enable us to have a better
health
more more gps um
to keep our services and perhaps expand
our services at qeqm in order to
accommodate
such a potential large influx of
residents
okay yeah um infrastructure is always a
quite difficult issue because
although we have to have regard to
infrastructure delivery and we have to
prepare an infrastructure delivery plan
which again on the website
but and i can direct people to different
things if they'd like to see those
but obviously with infrastructure we are
dependent on other organizations
so there is we off we have had
in the past lots of conversations with
both the clinical commissioning group
uh we've had uh correspondence and
discussions with nhs
trust with kcc
in terms of their education
commissioning plan
so yes i accept
that there are other issues that need to
be addressed from a planning point of
view all we can do is look at
making sure that the facilities are
there that we are tying in with the
various commissioning plans
um and yes i mean certainly the ccg
have said to us in the past that part of
the issue is about recruitment
and they have looked at different ways
of doing that
but from a planning point of view we
need to just make sure that we are
making available sufficient
sites or and facilities
to enable that provision um
but clearly we are relying on other
organizations for delivery as well
so in terms of the education
commissioning plan as well
kcc run that and they look at the
planning for the schools
we try and reflect that in the plan in
terms of what provision we make
for sites and the same is true for the
ccg
hence why you know on some sites we're
suggesting
and requiring uh the provision
of actual surgery space and in some
cases
there are contributions to surgery
provision or
or to ccg programs but it's not
it's not a perfect answer because as i
say we are dependent on other
organizations
but obviously our role is to make sure
we're doing everything we can to support
their programs thanks thanks very much
agent
the the problem is that the ccg have
been aware for a few years that we are
short of gps this is just one angle i'm
not going onto the hospital angle
because i keep it simple
um but we've been short of gp start you
know in
in shockingly short of gps for years
and they've been aware of that and they
say
there is nothing they can do nothing
more they can do
and um it's impossible to recruit and i
i don't think that's acceptable i think
that there is things they could do
they haven't done thought of golden
handshakes they aren't thinking about
incentives then
they say they won't um but in this
situation that might be an idea
it's not just the building you know that
is not we can't have
it's okay having a gp surgery on
extension but if you can't get the gps
here to man it
then there's no point so
i'm concerned that they aren't listening
to that
okay well we will certainly be having
discussions with the ccg again
as part of the update process um and we
can certainly raise those issues with
them
um it's not something that you know
we we can guarantee if you like but
certainly we will we can have
discussions with them
and find out what their current plans
are and try and work with their
commissioning plans as best we can
thank you yeah i mean if it's about you
know then providing money for gp surgery
building then
they then there could be an issue around
incentives
providing incentives as well but
obviously that's up to them but
there are possibilities thanks
thank you uh council bayford
yeah thank you chairman um adrian i
wonder whether you could elaborate a bit
about
um the the potential um
influence that the decision-making over
manson
will have on the process i mean what's
your best guess of
when decisions will finally be made
given it could be some way away i mean
does it mean you also have to have a
plan a and a plan b
going forward because if it's not going
to be an airport presumably it will be
something else
yeah um thank you for that um
uh as you say i'm glad you asked me that
question
um yes i mean it's quite a difficult
issue because clearly
uh you know it is a large site um
the decision on uh on the dco
could be quite critical in terms of how
we approach different strategies
um so i think uh as things stand
our our intention is to sort of press
on and hope that the decision is made
a final decision whatever that decision
is is made
during the month as we're progressing
the plan
um so that by the time we get to submit
a plan for examination
there's there's hopefully a very clear
picture of what's happened
what the strategy is going forward and
you know what we need to put in the plan
to reflect that decision
it is a difficult one um but i think we
just need to press on
uh with the local plan and await that
decision and
we'll then have to make some some
decisions about that
sorry if that doesn't really answer the
question but it's quite a difficult one
i think it would have been quite an
achievement if you happen to have to
answer the question was development
counselor bailey hi good evening
thank you for the presentation adrian um
yeah i mean
my concern is still i have brought this
up before i think
um the disconnect or how the council
addresses the disconnect between the the
public's
perceived um
uh what's the word i want uh
need their their their perception of our
need for housing and then
and then total number of housing um
yeah that we have imposed on us the 17
000.
you know you hear all the time that oh
we don't want all these people coming
and we don't need all these houses and
and i think you know with all these big
projects coming up with these big
developments coming up
there's already with the shot and day
one last week i mean there's already so
much resistance to them i just
it just looks like it's gonna be a huge
battle going forward for the next few
years
and obviously that will affect the you
know things like infrastructure like
in a ring road and things like that i i
just wonder if there's any way that we
can
explain it more clearly to the public
yeah i mean that that is that is
entirely a fair point and
um it's a discussion
we have quite a lot about whether we can
explain it more clearly i mean
fundamentally it
is a government methodology that we have
to follow
it is based on population growth
rather than anything else so it doesn't
relate
um a lot of people say well we don't
need housing we need jobs
but but the the housing number is
predicated on
the anticipated population growth and
that's natural growth within
the district people moving out and
people moving in
and it's and what the government figures
do
is to look at the total population
growth and how many households that is
so uh i can understand why people find
that difficult and we certainly had some
discussions at the examination last time
about that
and i think you might have been there
for for some of that
and uh but i think we we perhaps need to
do
to try and find ways to explain that um
more clearly
to local people if we can i don't think
it necessarily
will lev you know lower the level of the
fact that people
feel um that it's being foisted upon
them i don't
necessarily think we we can resolve that
issue
uh very simply but certainly i think we
can try and engage with people
more and try and explain uh how those
figures come about
and why we have to plan for them
i think if i can just comment on that i
think one of the
one of the things the council can do one
of the things that members can do is
inform themselves about the process
as far as possible because
understandably
members get members of the public coming
to them and saying why are we building
these houses we don't want these houses
so
the better understanding that
counsellors have in the process and i
know quite a lot of work has been done
and is being done
to try and communicate the the issues
more clearly perhaps than than
has been done in the past because it is
difficult and it's always easy
it's always easy to say to the president
oh well we agree with you but in reality
um we're not in control of a lot of
these variables mr paulson wanted to
come in i think
thank you um yeah just to add to what
adrian
said about the numbers i think there's
there's also a conversation to have
about the
the type of homes that are delivered um
and the cost of those homes um and that
is
something that potentially could um you
know
chime with local residents who's
extended family children or they know
people that
can't afford to access the home they
need and the local plan does include
policies about how we can um
encourage the the size and type of home
to be
constructed that meets a locally
identified housing need
and and also policies about the cost and
the delivery of affordable housing as a
as part of that total housing number um
so those are things that
directly relate to some of the things
that the local community need and
you know worth talking about when when
uh when it's raised with you
thank you um counselor ashby you've got
your hand up i'm not sure whether that's
an old hand or a current one
no um there's a current one chair sorry
yeah it is an old hand because it's
the same age as me unfortunately so
that's all
but this one is not historical hand if
i just would like to know um and i've
tried to find it out rather
via the plan but um can you tell me what
the designated status is of the huge
site in central margate
for the old royal school for the deaf
because when we
talk about call for sites um i've got an
awful feeling that this is a bit of land
banking by kcc
maybe i don't know i could be wrong but
i i could
could you just clarify what the status
is of that i mean that is a massive
massive plot so um if you could
confirm that adrian that would be great
yeah sure um
it was we didn't include it in the last
local plan
for any particular purpose because at
the early stages there wasn't a
particular proposal for it
um you'll probably be aware of all the
discussions about it being a secondary
school
and the discussions that kcc had with
government
in the end i i don't think that
finally came to anything so um
it is a site that will no doubt come
forward at some stage in the new local
plan process
um and well
we haven't seen anything from kcc yet in
terms of land proposals but they will
usually bring things forward
um whatever comes through the call for
science uh
in terms of the actual science will will
be made public
at some point but obviously we'll bring
all that back to this group
uh for a discussion so i think there's
there's two things here one is what
comes through the call for science and
obviously
uh as i was referencing earlier our
discussions with
kcc on their education commissioning
plan
and how that might change in the future
as well
okay um so can i just come back on that
i mean i'd hate obviously you say the
call for science finishes on the 21st of
may but if they creep past that point
um i mean it's a it's a huge brownfield
site isn't it and it would take a lot of
pressure off of some of the other areas
that uh
you know obviously we have an issue with
with farmers
um on the call for sites it tends to be
farmers
trying to sell off their their
agricultural land um
for obviously increasing the value of
their agricultural va
uh land which will not be cured until
such
times as the as the chancellor decides
to charge farmers for
uh capital gains tax on the difference
between the price of farming land and
building land but
you know it just seems to me that that
that site has been sat there for
i think it's what i don't know how long
the royal call for the death i think
it's about
five or six years now and it and it's
just a criminal waste um
maybe we could i mean is there some
pressure that can be applied for
for them to decide what they want to do
with it i mean if it's not going to be a
school
it just makes such an obvious great site
for
for a lot of a lot of housing so um you
know just like to to flag that up really
thank you
yeah i mean certainly we will be having
conversations with kcc
about various things so certainly we can
raise that with them
whether they've got any specific
intentions themselves for the site
or we can have a discussion about what
it might be used for going forward
all right sir uh mr paulson you've still
got your hand up i'm not sure whether
you
intended to come in again oh no it's no
i didn't take it down sorry
all right we always start these meetings
say we're going to use the chat then
everybody uses the hands
so we'll probably have to try and be a
bit more disciplined about that
councillor bathroom
yeah thank you chairman um yeah coming
back to the the housing
again i mean we obviously got this
problem of
you know need for housing and people
don't want
big sites near them and all those good
things i mean
is there any possibility that building
upwards could become
part of the solution to that and the
other thing is i mean
can you comment on obviously we're a
rapidly aging population and there's
going to be a lot of people sort of
trading down sheltered accommodation and
whatever
i mean how does things like sheltered
accommodation figure in
the actual housing units i mean does
that take some pressure off the numbers
yeah um yes i mean certainly in certain
locations of the district
you know building upwards could
contribute um to the housing numbers
various institutional uses
[Music]
care homes can make a contribution it's
a slightly complicated
formula that you have to use to work out
how many housing numbers
it creates but and the same is true for
sheltered accommodation that a certain
number will add you know
a certain number of sheltered rooms will
add up to one house
in the government's methodology so we
will count all of those
as part of the housing numbers uh we
also
probably recall from last time we also
count some empty properties coming back
into use as well so
all that gets counted in the numbers
okay thank you
okay fellows yeah thank you
uh two things um it's quite clear that
we need more affordable housing in
planet
and and part of the one of the policies
main policies in the local plan was
30 affordable housing on every site
now we've got developers now um holding
the council to ransom
because they've got to build a
roundabout or a road through their site
saying that well we won't build that
unless we we can
lower the affordable housing targets now
if they're not
affordable then they're obviously
unaffordable so i mean why are we now
you know low in the targets that that's
one of the stipulation policies of our
local plan
well i i won't comment on the individual
planning applications because obviously
you know that that's a matter for the
planning applications team but
um in all of these cases there is often
an issue and it's not
by any means limited to than it um the
issues of affordability
so um in viability rather so when you're
looking at a particular site
we carried out a viability assessment
for the local plan that's obviously very
high level
but when you look at some sites there
may be particular
costs in terms of building
a particular cost in terms of clear up
costs
uh infrastructure provision and so on so
yes the policy is 30 and that's what we
want to get
and arguably we could in terms of need
actually ask for more but we have to
picture a level which we think is viable
for most sites
so there is a each case
where they're not going to provide the
affordable housing at 30
they have to provide a viability
assessment for their site
um those viability assessments
are independently assessed for us
by viability consultants uh the same
people who did the local plan
work as well um inevitably there will be
some giving that if
the site cannot deliver everything and
it's it is not
an easy decision but um
the case officer the individual case
officers will obviously prepare a report
based on
the viability advice they've been given
um and
trying to give you as members of
prioritization of
what needs to be delivered
but it is a difficult set of decisions
to make
yeah i mean i i appreciate that you know
that you know infrastructure needs to be
paid for but
especially along this north coast belt
here where we've got westgate merchants
and garland et cetera where
the deliver developers have got to
contribute to all the infrastructure
that's going to go in
they're all going to demand that the
affordable targets are lowered
you know and you know we're at the point
where you know people be happy if there
were more affordable housing to be built
yet the developers are asking for less
so i think we need to stick to our guns
and
stick to the 30 and not trying to lower
it to 10 where what developers are
asking for
i mean the other thing i would say about
the inner circuit in particular is
that we are supporting a kcc bid
for what's called main road network
funding mrn funding
which is a bid to government for about
40 million pounds
so we are looking at other sources of
funding for some of the infrastructure
as well
yeah i appreciate that and the other
point was what is the current status of
the mansion and green development
because that
plan of mission was given over five
years ago now so
i mean that obviously expired now so
what's going to happen with the 780
homes
uh that we're going to be built there i
don't know what the current position is
in terms of
any um discussions that are going on
with the planning applications team
about any
uh resubmission um obviously we would
want that site to come back in
and meet its full you know make its full
provision
i'd need to speak to ian livingstone
about that and i can come back to you on
that council fellows if that would help
okay thanks okay and i've got councillor
bailey
yeah just a quick one um is there an
actual figure for the additional number
of houses
we need um between between 2031 and 2040
the additional plan period um we haven't
got a final figure yet
but oh it's believed to be in the region
of about four thousand
if you remember uh earlier sorry not
earlier this year last year
uh there was discussion about changing
the standard
methodology and gl hearn i think
presented two different figures to this
group
um a while back based on the two
different methodologies
you know you'll probably also remember
all the um
discussions and debate about what was
called the mutant algorithm
um and then the methodology was changed
again
uh so we're just waiting for a final
figure based on
the third version of the methodology
um but it it will be in the region of
4000
i think so will that require more
infrastructure
like road networks well i think i'd
what we'll do is once we know what that
figure is we will write to
the various infrastructure providers
we'll also talk to kcc highways
about what needs to be done from a
highways point of view i think the idea
with the inner circuit was to try to
build in
some resilience longer term um
but there are obviously potential
infrastructure
requirements and whether that's
educational health or other things that
might be associated with the additional
housing so yes that is a set of
discussions that we all need to have and
obviously we'll
come back to members on that when we've
had that discussion
thank you okay well thank you for that
agent i think that's been a useful
discussion and no doubt we'll return to
many of those
topics over the over the run of meetings
of the group
um should we move on to the work program
which has been circulated
would you want to introduce that uh yeah
thank you uh
um what we've set out there uh is
quite an intense program really it's a
meeting roughly every three weeks
uh right through to september
to try and cover all the various topics
that were mentioned
in the presentation earlier the
different aspects of it
um one thing i would ask you to bear in
mind is to
is the little note at the bottom that
says the topic order may be changed
this is obviously topic to how our
discussions
uh go with other organizations uh when
various government decisions are made
about different things
um and when uh studying finish
we will obviously try and make sure we
cover all the topics
um appropriate time
um but it is quite an intensive program
i appreciate that there's quite a lot to
cover
in the time available so again
happily answer any questions on that
okay we've got councillor garner
i think
yeah thank you as you say um
a challenging um program of of um topics
to cover
especially i'm looking at it on one or
two of them
they're in some of these meetings might
have to
last over two hours i would have thought
you know we've got one meeting with
porter brandy and the airport dco
and i'm i sort of got concerned that
some of the other ones at the the end
might drop off and be
forgotten so can we be assured that
they're look that we
i don't think we'll be forgetting any
topics uh councillor ghana right not
forgotten
but running out of time i rather suspect
there'll be nothing to say about the
airport dco but
we'll have to see when we get there um
we sorry i could say we have had a
discussion about this
uh in in the in the team as well about
whether we've got the balance of topics
right in terms of how big some of the
topics are
so it may be that we sort of slightly
rearrange topics so that
some of the more weighty ones are
perhaps balanced with
with some of the smaller topics to try
and uh
keep the the agendas fairly consistent
but
we yeah it does we will definitely be
trying to cover all those topics as part
of this program
okay um counselor buddy you've got your
hand up did you want to speak on this or
have you
okay sorry that was an old one okay
thank you okay do members have any other
questions about the work program
i'm not seeing any so um the next
meeting's on monday the 17th of february
and we're proposing then to talk about
the uh retail store presentation on the
retail study
uh did i say february may 7th may and
the local housing needs assessment
okay let me go back to my agenda
chairman can you tell me what what time
would that meeting be
i think the assumption was that these
meetings will be at 5 30 is there a
feeling that they shouldn't be at 5 30.
no well not not particularly just
the 17th of may i know is is the um
broadstairs
uh town council annual meeting and mayor
making and so
a couple of us would be affected by that
potentially
right okay
right so if that's the um the work
program
and i'm sure that um we'll move
forward on that do members have any
other questions before we close
tonight's meeting of the group
i've got councillor hopkinson
that's the hopkins in there
can you hear me now yeah that's better
yeah um
just note that the next uh matey's got
two presentations
i just wondered to what extent we can
get some of the information in advance
beforehand
or you know perhaps it's not needed or
appropriate but it's
perhaps if well we'll have a think about
what we might be able to provide
ahead of the meeting so that you can see
um
some of that uh certainly it might be
that on the local needs housing
assessment or perhaps can provide a no
ahead of it because that will be a
presentation
or an introduction to um
a report from us uh the sonic retail
study will be a presentation from
the external consultant so probably may
not be able to get that ahead of time
but we'll certainly have a look at that
yes
i think any sort of um framework as to
what's been
going to be discussed might be useful
because we have got members with
different levels of experience here
obviously and
uh um the quicker we can get to the meat
of the business the better really
um council fellows did you want to come
in yeah just quick
about future meetings are they going to
continue to be virtual or we've got to
be back in the chamber for
the meetings well there's a discussion i
think to be had around that i mean at
the moment
these meetings because those meetings
are informal whatever the legislation we
can hold
cabinet advisory group meetings online
um i think i think some of us find that
more convenient for meetings of this
type but
i think there needs to be a bigger
discussion among members generally about
how meetings are held going forward
yeah especially at this time of day as
well yeah
okay um
um yeah thanks chair this is just a very
um
basic general question but one of the
things that residents
are obviously saying is um
who is going to live in these houses
that are proposed
to be built in sanet and
it's it obviously is a very large number
and i'm not
sure how to answer that to be honest um
obviously there's a projected growth
but i'd be really grateful from some
advice
about how to answer residents questions
from that point of view um
yes i mean just in general terms uh
it is it tends to be a mix so it's
either
people moving house within the district
to something larger or smaller
it's often uh children moving out of the
family
home uh when they you know uh have
get their own homes or or start families
and so they they uh have a need for a
their own home we do have people moving
into the district as well
uh some people move in uh
at retirement some people uh move here
where
they're still working and then retire to
the area so it's quite a mix of um
different groups that are that take up
the housing
[Music]
what we could perhaps do is to try and
elaborate on that a little bit as part
of
the report for the local housing needs
assessment
at the next meeting yes it would i mean
it's it's just that on the face of it
we're we're an area of you know low
employment
um we don't see that changing uh
that rapidly that we're going to become
a high employing area
and it's an awful lot of houses so yeah
as you say that that accommodates some
of the question but it is an awful lot
of houses
and there isn't the work here and i
think that's what people are
asking so yeah that would be great and
have more more
more ability to answer that question
thank you
i suspect council fans that if um if
there are people to buy the houses
and then when we talk about the ones
that are obviously for sale at
market prices then the developers won't
build them
and i think some people sometimes people
do get a bit
caught up in what the plan says and as
we know the plan is a plan
and the market determines what gets
delivered by and large
um so it's not always the case that
we're going to build
lots of empty houses i don't think we're
in a position like parts of london
perhaps where there are
very large numbers of flats being built
simply as a sort of um
financial little hedge yeah i don't
think we've got that in fact
very much so no no i totally agree and
that is one of the answers that i give
um but that's quite hard for people when
they you know
passionate about their farmland and our
green space
is quite difficult um i think that
and also obviously in such one of the
first areas that's been
discussed at planning has been in my
ward and it's a difficult area it's
already been established it's it's not
easy to build on
there's the um steep incline there's all
the
infrastructure there's the flooding so
if all the areas
weren't going to be built on it seems to
me that that particular area might be
one of should be one of the last in fact
because of
the expense of the infrastructure as
i've heard it last week
so yeah unfortunately the council
doesn't have to
doesn't have the ability to dictate
which areas are developed first in in
absolute terms
and it does it does largely come back to
the market i think
council hopkins and you've got a hand up
did you want to come in again or was
that a
an old one sorry that's just an old hand
sorry
okay all right if there's no other
questions members then i'm going to
close the meeting i think that's been a
useful session
thank you to officers uh mr vero in
particular for their time this evening
thank you members and i look forward to
seeing everybody on the 17th of may
have a good evening